viril van djk is the is the yard stick
for your best at this current stage civa
is a better Defender he's the best in
the world statistically or what you can
do statistic I I don't like to do stats
he is the best in the world right now
CBA is better right now than v
v Cheers
Cheers there we go all right all right
could see I love this shirt by the way
thank you very much this is a Grail top
stand up speak up yeah got T on the back
the greatest Premier League player um
what oh not agree okay most people not
far off not far off okay okay I'm sure
we'll get into it at this stage but yes
yeah it started already my bad my
bad Arsenal will win their next trophy
before Liverpool win their next trophy
three two one yeah um I want to go
strongly agree I'm going to go here
um I'm I'm going to go in between I I
believe we'll win silverware this year
and it's it's either What I've Done
these predictions already it's either an
FA Cup or a League Cup it's not the
major one which is still a major one FA
Cup but I don't give me that face in the
FAA cup or the efl cup is what you're
willing to venture I was sitting there
going well maybe we'll get the Premier
League before those guys maybe we'll get
well maybe if we're I don't even think
if we're lucky if we just doce anything
in Europe then cool we can win
silverware before you guys do m I and
frankly I don't even consider the CBS to
be a silverware anymore wow cuz we're
looking above them let's talk about
whether you win one of the big tropies
cuz that's going to make it actually
interesting do you win a premier league
or a Champions League before we win one
honestly Champions League I think
Liverpool will do it before us however I
think we'll win the Premier League what
way of talking is this I don't
understand the the mentality we will win
the Premier League I believe before you
next you know when you play poker you
have to check your cards again that what
that felt like I just remember I'm
trying to re reaffirm my my power but
just now I didn't need to recheck my
cards cuz I just know that there is
going to be another massive win in this
Yogen Klo era but the point is still
you what you did was you discounted the
Champions League you said you will not
win that before we win it despite the
fact that really you might be the second
third third fourth because there's
there's still Real Madrid in there city
were going to be in there in terms of
English teams you're the second best
English team in the Champions League
this season yeah English teams wise the
I think the only team that you guys
don't really knock out is Man City I
hear that look more confident and if you
are confident tell your face like
seriously agree or
disagree no I just I believe the Premier
League over the I generally believe
we'll win the Premier League is that
that's what you want are you guys just
going look we want the Premier League
I've never seen Arsenal Inn the
Champions League so I'd rather I'd
rather see that I just feel the because
of because of last season I just feel
like we've learned so much from last
season it's a young team that are
deducing all the information downloading
everything that they've experienced and
the feelings and they're just putting it
in to their stride as much as we haven't
kicked off as fast as we did last season
I believe they're learning so much that
eventually they'll get over the line
before the Champions League we've it's
been six years since we've been back
into the Champions League L and I don't
know I feel like it's a big ask for us
to go on and win that pretty quickly in
the next why not just be a little bit
confident I I believe just you know I
like lence yeah I you like I've got more
confidence in your side than you do
you're as scarred as I was a couple of
seasons ago Second City and it was like
again you're in that phase yeah the
Shameless side it does come out it's
going to come it comes back right now
I'm just I am scarred of what we saw
last season but I this is I believe it's
Premier League of the Champions bring it
out let me see the Shameless side a
little bit otherwise we're just going to
be too nice to each other the whole time
okay the Shameless side's coming don't
worry coming all right cheers here's to
your
shamelessness still disagree
we genuinely we win a premier league or
a Champions League before you do again
no it's not happening Premier League we
win it this
[Laughter]
season
yeah man for man Arsenal have a better
start in 11 than Liverpool 3 2
1 why you got to do that you asked for
Shameless CES he has
arrived oh this is this is like just
before shame the CLE comes out this is
like David and Goliath I get it but
remember who won
that I'm happy for you to make your case
first but I'd be very happy to just
obliterate it and then you don't even
need to reply no you you go first okay
you go first best goalkeeper in the
world uh a center back who your your
best center back is always compared to
another Center back who is basically in
waiting and another backup center back
to that who is incredible you can choose
joh John mati or Joe Gomez either of
which I don't mind Gabrielle Mages beats
them both sure but that's not my point
here okay canate is equal
to him and Virgil Van djk is the is the
yard stick for your best is our yard but
he is better at this current stage civa
is a better Defender he's the best in
the world Sor say statistically or what
well you can do statistic I I don't like
to do stats but going to away from that
right now from what you have seen
visually and and from my eyes and what I
generally believe he's the best I see it
visually mostly he's the best he is the
best in the world right now SBA is
better right now than Virgil Van di
we're not going to we're going to have
to do the whole 11 but right now I say
I'll give you Trent we're not going to
conversate about left
back who who would you put
forward I'm going to have to go
zinchenko Andy Robertson has been that
left back in the Premier League of this
era right for so long
now and I think he's I don't think you
can make a massive argument that zenko
is like defensively a better left back
Andy Robertson I can't I can't and I'll
give you that that's free for you but
when we come into Midfield lence now
three you got you obiously because you
guys can't decide yeah yeah Ramel sorry
I like Ramel but my manager doesn't Cent
back each I'm not doing that I can't so
you're saying you want both your center
backs in there CRA and Gabrielle
Lawrence Virgil Van Dyk you can say name
it's not syllables in the name we're
comparing here
quality right now you have to agree you
have to Cela and Gabrielle right now are
the best pairing in the Premier League
Virgil Van DJ cannot not be in this best
starting 11 and he can't but then celba
but for the balance celba has to be in
it which means Virgil can't be in it and
the the next pairing is to the left side
of him is Gabrielle and they're the best
the argument here is they're the best
center back pairing right now in the
Premier League there's there's not much
else like that's that's the facts but at
the same time that would be a better
Center back pairing if you put Virgil
Van djk as the other Center
back we're going to go into Midfield so
as long as I I take all three
midfielders then we can agree on this
because you're Midfield do sp has been
phenomenal for you guys
but I can brush Rego on that one fair
enough but if we put in a Thomas part
Declan rice and Mar not God you're
telling me that Thomas parte is better
than any of those Liverpool three that
they bought in the summer when he's when
he's playing arguably but he's not
to put him in there who's had a bigger
influence on the Midfield this season
sasai or when P's in the side I'm
telling you has we he's who's been fit
who's played more games so has yes
agreed but that but when it comes to the
strongest fre in Midfield right now if
they're all fit that is it that is it
that is your weakest area at Liverpool
and you you I know but with production
just they nodded and when I said fully
they go yes so visually I didn't see
that the VIS I'm very good of visuals
the so the Midfield three like I said
partake rice odard then on the right
we'll start with the right attackers we
got sacka and then on the left we got
Martinelli you're looking at me
bewildered and then up front there I I I
don't really rate
Nunes and I'm going to get a lot of
stick for that because he is starting to
hit great form this is a coming rage for
him this season and we're seeing a
striker who has finally found the
position he plays in has a great
relationship with arguably one of the
most iconic players of all time who
definitely play on the right win for
this team which is no Salah obviously
ahead of sacka you you genuinely just
tried to slip that in I thought you
would I thought you would ni but on the
left I I mean I can maybe give you
Martin Elliot a push I think I think I
think that's makes sense Martin Elliot
is on the left and not even not even
just you will agree with that your
manager does as well klopp loves M
absolutely loves it and I'm fine with
that so that's fine and then up front
that's right I'll give you I'll give you
nunet but we we count the players free
in Midfield from Arsenal two set back
pairing uh we didn't actually agree on
that with Fair Play It's actually that's
four and then in your front front three
you actually have one so I've got six
players you got five which actually
means that this strongly disagree just
statistically was correct I'd rather
have meleta as my manager than Jurgen
clo 3 2
1 yes you feel all right about that I
feel very good about that okay listen
jgen CL fantastic manager I mean he's
he's he's pretty much won all Champions
League Premier League yeah he's won he's
won a League Cup he's won two managers
of the seasons buers League yeah for
Liverpool he's done very well but Etta
what we sorry we're just doing Liverpool
are we no because arteta such a long
track record before my bad yeah I think
that actually benefits him in a sense
because it's his first managerial job
and look what he's done for Arsenal so
far okay he's come in he's changed the
whole culture um he's he's got us
competing again he's made me me
personally fall back in love with my
club um going to games the atmosphere
the vibe and he done a clear out he took
risks made big changes I think is is on
the verge
to yes matching or even take surpassing
KS Legacy at Liverpool okay so I'd
rather him be our man my manager with
Clark the only reason I'd say he edges
artetta for me and what I'm looking for
in a
manager is I feel there's a different
connection between the Liverpool fans
and klopp and the the the one that tet
with Arsenal fans and the reason I could
say that is different is because I do
feel like Jurgen klopp was tailor made
for Liverpool I agreed and if he if
arteta came to Liverpool I don't think
he'd be the same kind of relationship
and that I agree with as well so the
reason I strongly disagree is he like
it's Yan Clark we have disagreed but I
think we're can agree to disagree that
you know respect respectfully 100% I at
the same time I'm
right just for the just for the format
I'm right you're not you're not okay so
here's the argument right would you
trade
managers so say tomorrow you traded
managers I think you're happier with
that than we are I don't think so I
don't think I
don't because what what he's done for us
as well just don't forget klopp
inherited a better side than what
artetta did he still ended up we didn't
end up Europe but we W fa he did you had
inherited a better side from Brendan
Rogers Club did yeah compared to what we
had do you know we had Mareno we had sa
bro do you know what we had we had Simon
Min in gold you did you understand the
pain you had hendo you had Gomez you had
skirt you still had a good you still had
quite a good Martin skirt I like okay
good but like but we inherited a worse
worse a team I I disagree with that I
think you actually inherited a pretty
decent side but but not not to the
degree that was going to get you
anywhere where you wanted to get to so
no disrespect to the Arsenal team but
the Arsenal team that was being built
was not what michetta want so do you
believe and I'm taking putting the
question in do you believe klopp still
has do you think he guys has more to go
you think he can still take this
Liverpool side back to compete and maybe
win trophies compared to the trajectory
that arteta has right now you you've got
an argument as to CL being able to
achieve it just purely on the fact that
he has already achieved what m arteta is
trying to achieve and he's done it in
the Champions League he's done it in the
Premier League he's done it in other
leagues as well where he's beaten the
side that is meant to be like the best
team in the league so we've beaten Man
City arguably the best Premier League
team of all time we're the only other
side apart from you to push Man City to
any extent in the league and arguably
pushed them further than Arsenal did no
disrespect to Arsenal but one points
difference couple of points difference
for a couple of Seasons arguably you
guys fell away at the end I don't think
that's unfair to say right so we went
further than they went and earlier than
they went and klopp has got that he's
already done that so why not do it again
I hear you I do hear you but I just feel
like this Liverpool competing with City
maybe when I still feel like art is it's
time for his is he's being him it's time
for his Arc to start going and we're
going to see the Liverpool slowly
changing it be more City Arsenal City
arsal I think they're the closest I
think every Manchester United looked at
jgen klopp he would have been credible
for them City would have wanted Jurgen
Club Liverpool wanted him Arsenal wanted
him Spurs would have been begging to
have him the Bundesliga any side in that
team in that League wants him Germany
want him arguably there is not a side in
Europe that wouldn't
go yeah probably worth a hit I yeah last
season Real Madrid wanted Mel I mean it
happens sure but they also wanted Jan
Club up last season as well the only
reason that everyone thought last season
that Real Madrid wanted Jurgen karpp or
M whoever it was was easy clicks we know
it's not a real headline oh oh okay I
put some truth into that was say you
know man City's next manager potentially
will be M AR who they want might be
clicks but I see some truth in as well
considering how much arter has done to
change the culture at Arsenal Football
Club and listen I knew would strongly
agree and disagree on this for that
because I think we're so attached
Liverpool will always be a bigger Club
than Arsenal 3 2 one are we allowed to
remain these on the line yeah that's
that's a tough one okay sorry always
remain no but this is this one's a hard
one I think the reason we are bigger is
purely the Head Start that we have in
Europe and that record that yeah you're
European arguably some of the best best
managers of all time have helped right
so you got obviously uh shankley built
it Paisley made it incredible and then
you know Kenny and all those guys came
in and just finished it off and then
since then it's not that that was just
an era like we've done it with arguably
one of the worst Liverpool teams of all
time because we're such a big Club you
guys not to bring up traumatic memories
but like stumbled at the line arguably
with your greatest team until now right
yeah we did it with Jimmy tror at left
back we did it with de DD Haman in
defensive Midfield Harry K was in that
team at one point Milan baros was a
striker for us like the guy on your
back he didn't quite get it over the
line and that's what that's why big what
he done but as what he done for just
football in General T and re for and
again I'm going personal as well a
sports club because of my idolization
for T but what he' done for the Premier
League most people say as much as you
started this he is the greatest
footballer to touch the Premier League
he I don't disagree with that
necessarily I just think there's like a
couple of people who are in that mix
yeah in the mix but if we're talking
about the number one he is there and and
and made Arsenal a massive brand on top
of obviously the success previously as
well Wenger the golden Invincible trophy
um that is is huge that's that's known
it's made us it's made us huge I've
traveled the world following Arsenal and
I've seen how big this club is um it's
it's massive from that from you know the
past of it the the class of it the way
we play football the it is Arsenal's is
a massive Club I I agree when you say
your European Heritage is is what we we
lack and and that's the only difference
and it it it pains me and it's yeah but
it's not it's not like it's like we win
three and then we're sort of level it's
like there's six of but then again
football's going to continue way before
when we're in the in the Box in the
ground and and things can definitely
change but it's fine like the point is
that we there's six of those to make up
and city city who spent more than you
they've had more dominance than you guys
they've got a sixth of how many we have
mhm just to remember that they got a
Sith of how many we have right I hear we
saying but the other argument to it is
our Premier League I'm not going to say
heritage there only been three Premier
League trophies but again that's what on
the other hand is what you're partly
lacking as well so we but you've got you
you win one you've got a sixth we win
another one we've got two3 as many of
you that's just infractions I understand
this thank you for the math lesson I
appreciate it I wasn't trying to teach
you but I'm just saying in the Premier
League is the greatest league in the
world the most followed league in the
world we're also in that League agreed
but we have more dominance to you than
than than what you have so as a club
worldwide people look at this fans
across the world that watch the Premier
League and look at that and we dominate
over you in that sense I all I can say
is you have more European Heritage and I
get that but that's why that's why I
don't think this argument is so it's
it's not it's on the line sure yeah yeah
we're not strongly disagree and it's
partially also just I like Arsenal but I
just think Liverpool Edge it in this
scenario and I don't think that's n
thing to say and it is because of the
Europeans stuff because it is so
ubiquitous because there is so much
success at Liverpool and there hasn't
ever really been an era where someone's
gone they are done we were close to
Banter Club but not as close as you guys
got that is what keeps us big Liverpool
will finish above Arsenal this season 3
2 1 o
o can I go between whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa W you don't see that
confidence you have hand on your glass
cuz I'm trying to figure out what we're
going to do here what you the fact that
thought hasn't hit you yet worries
me a little far strongly disagree you
know in curling where they go too far
you
overshock is just perfect you were like
scrubbing away we SL it was sliding it
was sliding it sliding but strongly
disagree I feel like we are we are the
closest to city um in my opinion and
they I think for me they're going to be
up there after January window when we
look at the tweaks where it's a striker
whether it's a midfielder I feel like
arsal will then kick on things aren't
click they haven't fully clicked but I
see us pushing and going going all the
way Arsenal's fully fit side is the best
in the league hands down fully fit 11
versus a fully fit 11 of your team or
cities we win so do you mean on paper or
when they actually play a game Arsenal
can beat anyone in the league if
everyone's fit I believe we can beat
yeah any team any team I think we're in
a band of teams where it's difficult to
differentiate between the three of them
three arguably like Peak managers at
operating close to their Peak I do want
to make a point as well is we have
beaten City already as well I know it's
at home we have beating him as well
so that also strengthens my argument in
the sense of I just feel like we will
just Edge you guys this this um season
but now I'm thinking will City be second
or Liverpool be second but that'll be
another debate well no I want to know
about
that now you start you can't Venture it
and take it back I I said this before
the season started I said that Arsenal
will come second and city will be top so
your predictions SKS aren't that good
but you're telling me about what no no
they're there they're there City can
still win it arsal can still be second
and you guys can be just behind right
and that's kind of how I see the top
three right now in my opinion looking at
Liverpool this season similar to Arsenal
they've not really clicked in the same
way but they found other ways to win
good mhm there are there is a Last Dance
type feeling for some of these players
around the club Virgil Van djk doesn't
know how much longer he can operate at
the very very top level and even if you
don't think he's is very Peak I still
think is a top level player Salah who
knows what happens at the end of the
season with him I think knowing that
Salah goes we just got to go all out
because this is my last opportunity to
do this and just goes crazy I mean he's
already been going pretty crazy this
season he's playing a whole new position
10 other people unbelievable nun is good
hacko like there's just loads of good
Liverpool players in there by the way
they didn't say do you think they win
the league and finish higher than the
other cuz it could still be they go City
Liverpool Arsenal this was me City
Arsenal Liverpool
all I care about is finishing above City
and I think whoever finishes above City
this season wins the league it's really
annoying I see it City then either us or
you I I believe it'll be us then you
that might change that may change it may
change it will change we'll win the
league this is a tough one Harry Kane
versus Cristiano
Ronaldo oh I've got the I've got I think
I've got the answer think
we're two one
Ronaldo you're useless right
what's wrong with you